well a south korean warship has now
become the latest battleground for
trying to combat the coronavirus around
the world it's an example of just how
aggressively the delta variant is now
fueling covert 19 surges
in just a week infections on board the
military vessel have gone from six
to almost the entire crew it comes as
south korea continues to fight its worst
outbreak at home
while southeast asian nations are also
struggling to contain the delta variant
indonesia is battling an oxygen shortage
and now has more daily infections than
india and brazil africa has recorded
fewer cases than other continents
but there has been a 40 jump in covert
19 deaths
just in the past week only around 1
of africans have been vaccinated still
though the us remains the worst affected
country
now every state is seeing a rise in
infections
still though confetti and countdowns
marked the start of what's being called
freedom day
as england lifts almost all restrictions
but scientists there warned that there
could be more than a hundred thousand
cases a day
in just a matter of weeks i will speak
to tony cheng in bangkok very shortly as
thailand expands its restrictions but
first let's get more on that outbreak on
board that south korean warship
with rob mcbride he's watching this for
us in seoul
rob the speed at which this spread that
is surely causing a huge amount of alarm
it is a very alarming outbreak given the
fact that this did seem to spread
through the entire ship's company in the
in the matter of just a few days uh
it is rather reminiscent of the outbreak
that uh
caught the u.s aircraft carrier way back
at the beginning of this pandemic in
march of last year that was similarly
stricken
in the pacific ocean warships uh we know
are incredibly vulnerable confined
spaces especially
below decks with very little chance for
large crews to socially
uh distance this is a much smaller ship
but it's no less alarming out of the
crew of some
300 247 testing
positive this destroyer is part of south
korea's contribution to the anti-piracy
task force off the
east coast of africa it still had
another month of its deployment to run
but that has now been prematurely
uh cut short as questions are being
asked here in south
korea about given the vulnerability why
hadn't the crew been vaccinated now the
military
have come under a lot of scrutiny they
have said that
there were logistical problems in
getting vaccines out to this ship
that may be true but they certainly have
much bigger logistical problems now they
have a stricken vessel
and a sick crew and the solution to it
is by no means easy
they have sent from south korea to
military aircraft to bring the entire
crew
back here to south korea those same
planes have taken out a replacement crew
a reduced
crew of 150 sailors whose job it is
now to bring this ill-fated vessel back
to south korean waters
robert bride there with all the latest
for us from seoul thank you so much rob